Was ist dein Tipp?
Wie wird "The Voice of Germany" enden?
Du willst, dass ich weissage wie Oktopus Paul, das Orakel?
Ganz genau, du sollst alles ueberblicken und vorhersehen.
Ein Mann? Eine Frau? Was denkst du, wie es endet?
Ich habe eine grobe Vorstellung
Aber das kann ich niemandem verraten, auf keinen Fall
Weil ich darauf wetten werde und das ganze Geld fŸr mich einstreichen kann
Ihr habt also Endprognosen bei euch im Team?
Nun, ich hab welche
Aber ich sage es niemanden
Wettet ihr unter euch darueber, wer gewinnt?
Nein, denn an diesem Punkt.. wo wir die Leute schon so viele Monate kennen..
Rae kennt sie nun schon etwas laenger als ich, aber trotzdem hatte ich
nun vier Monate die Gelegenheit dazu, sie naeher kennenzulernen
Und man bindet sich wirklich an die Leute
Man mag jeden aus anderen Gruenden und dann kann man nicht darauf wetten, wer von ihnen gehen muss
Naechste Woche wird wieder jemand gehen muessen
Und es wird sehr, sehr schlimm
Sie sind alle Freunde geworden
Ich steck meinen Kopf bei dem Thema gern in den Sand, wenn ich darueber nachdenke
Diese Show ist wirklich ein wenig traurig
So sehr du die Leute feierst, die weiterkommen und deren Spannung, das ist regelrecht ansteckend
so sehr denkst du auch an diejenigen, auf die du wartest und mit denen du dich gerne durchkŠmpfen willst
Also verliert man, obwohl man gewinnt
Denkst du nicht, dass viele der Saenger mehr Erfolg und mehr Chancen haben werden, wenn diese Show vorbei ist?
Ja, definitiv. Das tolle an "The Voice" ist, dass der Fokus im Gegensatz zu anderen Castingshows auf der Stimme liegt und auf der Musikalitaet
Darum denke ich, dass jeder, auch wer gehen musste, die Chance auf mehr Erfolg hat
Die Alben der Show sind ja bereits in den Top-Download Charts
Kann ich sagen Team Rea ist an der Spitze?
Wir rocken es!
Wir sind unF*CKINGfassbar, ich sag dir
Also, viel Glueck fŸr die naechsten Wochen